ah
[Music]
TGI the weekend rec pretty much
literally it's 6:30 here and on the East
Coast
yes it's it is pretty much the end of
the workweek for a upcoming three-day
weekend that I didn't know about no one
told me this yeah I found out like an
hour ago
apparently it's a holiday so we be
celebrating with some knievel action now
before we begin I just briefly want to
show some new fan art we've been doing
this once a week where we show some
awesome fan art that someone sent us
this is from Kaitlyn Kaitlyn is oh
that's cute and obviously budding artist
she is kids love us really starting up
there I for one was unaware that Kaitlyn
was watching this show and kudos to you
Kaitlyn because this is an intense show
it's stressful yeah I'm very proud of
you and I love how she captured your
boxy frame and your head yeah my torso
is looking a bit cubular lately that's
something you need to work on but she
captured my essence as well as you can
see I'm crowning I'm not blinking and
I'm screaming for help
Thank You Kaitlyn it's very cute I also
like the note yeah very much appreciated
that was a nice surprise so we're back
in the game I think what happened
actually a lot happened last episode I
died several times trying to get a knife
back I think that was two episodes all
right last episode was the one with the
dogs you were down in the parking garage
you met the police chief and Sherri I
had a boss fight that was less episode I
met mr. eyeball oh yeah William but now
you're in the police chief's office and
you have the diamond key yes um and a
better handgun oh I'm almost full here
so a drawer full a good question would
be what can I get rid of I obviously
don't need machine gun ammo because I
mean having a machine gun I made that on
accident but we both decided it was fine
yeah
yeah I don't uh probably not gonna look
at the roll of film anytime no like I
mean when you get to the darker and
there just say box next to it anyway so
you just take it out then you're done
now with a car key so I have three flash
grenades but they take two can I combine
these I think two might be the max you
could try sweet and you're done with a
car key it's red yeah you can discard
our store it either one so I have this
gun but I don't have any grenades for it
so I'm tempted to get rid of it unless
you're like get some grenades on you
you're definitely out of grenades even
in your save box you got acid rounds
okay yeah just in case I just I think
you should just be able to combine them
with the grenade launcher I also have
gunpowder which means I could make some
but I don't know how yet bring those
wooden parts well like all three but I'm
in the basement no remember you took the
elevator back up to the chief's office
you're right
people are not convinced I've played
this game because I keep telling you
like no you won't come back here and
then like later on I'm like oh wait I
think I think what that says though
isn't like that you're not knowledgeable
but how much this game it's like really
easy to to forget those types of things
like it's I've played not this game but
I played every Resident Evil if I played
them again I'd be like I think you're in
the middle of the game somewhere like I
don't know every like detail of that
game and like yeah one thing so I would
see you have your why not old handgun
equipped I would use I want to let me
combine these you might just have to
just reload it manually merge sorry
not manually but like outside of the
menu and as other people mentioned
remember you can do quick button pad to
switch your weapons right cool cool
let's say you have five rounds left in
your old handgun so I should get I would
use those just make sure you don't
reload don't reload cuz then you're
gonna eat into the handgun rounds that
you could use for your better handgun
it's instinctual for me to reload so
that's gonna be tough yeah you might I
mean you could just store it if you want
and then use those five later if you
need them I'll do my best
just saw my image glitch you're watching
gameplay right like yeah you can see me
- do I ever like glitch out there I
think so you didn't oh yeah you just did
okay
I've seven days there it is again you
just yeah
that's weird I will disable you Andrey
Abel you I hope that you just disabled
you and then rebuild you yes yeah that's
correct
the old off and on again and that stray
Lien's love those it doesn't work I
actually don't have a better solution
right now unplugging it so hopefully
that's enough oh [ __ ] I saw it do it
again give me one second okay no I don't
want to redo this besides upcoming evil
people this is my nightmare
so weird I saw it it was just working so
some items left oh you got it
machine gun magnum rounds no machine gun
round sorry Claire doesn't have a magnum
Graham plugged it okay
that's probably the best I can do for
now and if I see it do it a lot then
I'll have to buy a new frickin webcam
alright okay sorry for the delay it
looks like there's something on the
Chiefs desk oh sorry that table the sick
office those desk it's to the left this
is his desk this is a that's like a fake
desk so that if someone comes in with
it's an imposter yeah you like aim for
the desk and he's like huh I was sitting
here doing my tax return you really
don't need those submachine gun rounds
right now did I not put them away he
just picked up new ones
oh alright anything else now you should
be good alright where are we going and
what are we doing
you got the diamond key now so look for
Diamond doors that's a heart door yeah
my first failure this door must be the
one oh look at that a hot piece of
feline ass sorry I'm a cat I'm a cat
person
really look at that Tiger that tiger
that tiger has a world-class dumper
alright
sorry Caitlyn yes so I would say it look
for Diamond doors I know it's I think
there's one on the west side okay I mean
it'll show up on your map and we private
collection we know
I don't like anything this is a creepy
lot of antiques
dodo I don't know about that dodo
um power panel parts the old Triple P he
left one in the third floor East storage
room
clock tower stop oh my god sorry I'm on
edge aha
like a Leonardo da Vinci flying machine
thing on the left double key that's what
a [ __ ] what's this oh this is the
thing the what with the power is this a
game yeah power circuits maybe three
yeah
and there's a phone to call for help all
right well back week so what I'm trying
to think hey yeah I like it
stop it um it's not you can go through
that door I think if you want to go back
down to the garage for anything first
[Music]
oh it's a raccoon Oh whoopee
all right I'll use one of my shitty
bullets honey what'd I just say you can
knife it I don't have a knife oh oh I
know what you can do go downstairs first
I think you'll benefit more from that
all right and then what well you figure
it out no you figure it out no I'm not
leading you into anything I mean there's
gonna be guys down here but there
there's actually like important stuff
down here
all right you can pour it if you click
enough ah
I think that was the last heart door
nope nevermind I don't like this place
this is
do you think there's a guy on the end of
this mirror I don't know
obviously oh yeah I hear it falling when
I shake it to see what's in there it's
probably a grenade or a puppy
you never know okay that happened in the
original game but that doesn't happen
with Leon I knew it and it still upset
me it knows I'm here and I don't have a
key so there there is stuff in that room
that he came from
I think there's stuff worth getting okay
so a tick
you could try just being quiet oh no
he's gonna still be in there no I think
he followed me because I ran around like
a [ __ ] I don't think he liqueurs
can't open doors though what do you mean
yes
see he's still in there oh I'm out of
room can I combine also I'm I'm out of
room yeah I mean the the chief's office
is literally right above you can go back
there and get there pretty quick okay so
don't say you just do that yeah
you can also ditch the red and blue or
when you get back there
sorry this is really stressful do I need
the box right now yeah so remember that
red jewel you got from the art room
should be in here yeah Jimmy do that now
but yeah bejeweled
Bijou the badge it said oh no that's for
the computer somewhere else yeah it's in
the stars office do I need it right now
open your map I believe it's on the
other side west side up yeah I put it
away for now and then I probably don't
need both these hearts because I'm gonna
come right back here right are these
keys or do you think just you don't have
to come back here if you don't want to
UM but I'd put away your that hat the
first handgun for now she's the other
one the good one or the bad one should I
put away the bad one
all right I'm gonna go like I'm honestly
like I'm trying to remember whether it's
worth going into the liquor the other
side of the interrogation room try it
because like so the club key you don't
Clara never gets a club key it's that's
what Leon gets so you really do have to
see both sides of the story
yeah
[ __ ] you alright here we go
cuz this is something we've determined
is valuable I just get go to the hole in
the mirror and jump through there where
is it hole mirrors broken Oh liquor oh
maybe you can I jump through yeah so you
can jump through I'm just not sure if
he'll probably drop on you before you do
what makes you say that I just don't see
him letting you why okay my gut tells me
he's gonna drop on you when you try to
jump through that's my guess too maybe
you could try jump jump jump now keep
walking slowly though yeah oh man this
guy died pretty bad yeah six hot to 11
got it okay there's nothing there's
something else in this room or there's
nothing else in this area you got it
that's actually I'm glad we did that
because that's good to have so I can't
leave out that door so tell me this do I
need to I need to jump through that
window again right yeah yeah um what was
six to eleven I was I can read it again
six to alone
you might as well run oh he's off the
door now oh sweet that went well
what's I think that was the safe near
the art room so not too far from here I
got up one floor okay oh you never mind
you don't you you don't have the crank
to open the store yet yeah yeah I'll
just go upstairs then oh sure should I
go back and put some stuff away or no
mm-hmm
no I don't think you I mean your gun
powder you don't need but they give you
fun oh there's boys [ __ ] actually yeah
now that I think of it you probably
should put the Gunpowder away for now
I'm gonna get full RNA yeah all right so
I'm gonna go back there actually what
sorry clear out that room first the
lockers are separate there's lockers and
stuff here and then go clear out cuz
you're coming up to uh Jesus you have a
lot of those I think you can combined it
yeah I should've done that one okay I
think that's it go through these doors
or no I would deposit some stuff in the
save box all right it won't take very
long
and I'll also save just to be safe
oh four is the max 3x yeah you don't
need that fourth one I mean you never
know oh I forgot to save I'm such a
dumbass alright here we go
doesn't take very long and it makes me
feel a lot better about myself so I'm
gonna do it alright oh my god did you
hear that yeah
is it a liquor a zombie that's the
question you know umm alright so there's
a plant right in front of me
don't want this I hear it do you hear it
I hear it I hear him
he's a making noise what is that Oh what
do you think shoot him um yeah
Rizzy
I [ __ ] hate this it's like at the
smallest storage room ever or most
Cranston I hear another one I cannot
stab them I guess I wouldn't waste a
bullet I would just robably go wait you
can go around the other way yeah
you mean this way yeah just like circle
back around two doors where you want me
to go the balcony or to the main hall
I'm facing the way to next to the
balcony oh yeah yeah do you mean do that
now or later I do now okay so I'm gonna
leave this room and go to the balcony
yeah
no dogs
oh that makes me full oh no you you can
you can combine the blue with the red
and green oh yeah you might as well
actually at that point what's down there
should I go down there what is up on the
yeah I'm gonna go down there
like check every move I make with you
six seven times
I don't know if I want to do this
I in fresh hell
as a rudder
I can't go through here can i no it's on
fire still there's stairs at the other
end of the balcony to your right
I won't go down here what a noise
have you ever heard that whoops
she's a smoker
fell backwards on the stairs yeah Plus
gosh on the face four times that's not
dead
nice now she is nope
okay
she did what was that back up the stairs
okay did you hear it yeah I think you
just maybe under the stairs
they're so spooky in the dark like this
yeah you you're just standing there
calmly
[Music]
huh day down there you go
he took a lot holy [ __ ]
eight bullets hot mama
alright I can take this too but then I'm
full just leave it there for now
again I don't know what I'm doing that
just changed the water for the fire now
I can fix the fire there anything on
those drum and barrel oil drums back
there or in that wheel barrel all right
jerks probably could have done this
without shooting but you could get that
herb now I guess since you know you
don't need anything for a little bit
that's a [ __ ] mister can he come up
here she can go wherever he wants
you're doing such a bad job at guiding
me happen yeah but there so that's
locked go through that the white door
that'll corner you never mind that's
dumb
are you go to the stairs and then go but
is mr. X there he's going to be yeah
how's Clash banged my god did he not
come in here tell me what to do uh yeah
go that way go to this I went to the
wrong door again fine just do that to
get rid of the heart key you don't have
to go in there right now making them no
cuz he'll corner you he'll come in there
yeah now just go back toward the stair
he I think you still got him coming
around the bottom left of the room so
you should be able to go back to
breaking out oh I'm [ __ ] freaking out
I need to go down the stairs down yeah
yeah
go you [ __ ] idiot go does he come in
here you're not allowed to come in here
sweet now you can dump some stuff it's
res evil three except better you know
how I feel about Resident Evil three
yeah I thought that would have been the
last heart door damn
so you want to Dan that gear takes up so
much space I would store your grenades
your yellow acid grenades I can [ __ ]
hear him he's laughing at us do you hear
him yeah
but what am I gonna do with one acid
grenade I mean it just for an emergency
I don't think you'll need grenades at
all but just keep that for a number so I
can't kill this guy right
you can like stun him I would not waste
ammo on him what does he do if he
catches me it's not gonna be an instant
kill he'll punch you really hard is he
upstairs so you I don't want to go near
him so what so okay ultimately you want
to go remember when you lifted up the
helicopter you want to go back there cuz
that's your only way back to the rest of
the police station so you kind of like
you're in good shape you've lured him
into here now you just got to go back
out to the balcony I don't want to but
that's the only way out unless you go
back down into the parking garage which
also won't do any of these things I
should have done these first shouldn't I
yeah I mean you'll be able to come back
there yeah you can tell like I should
have killed those [ __ ] zombies in the
storage room that was my mistake
because then I had um zombie action plus
mr. X action it was too much action so I
would not go it's there looks like
there's an item's go down a floor again
okay so that's okay so you don't need to
go there so you definitely want to go
upstairs from here and then once you
come back around okay so here so you're
gonna go upstairs the east storage room
keep in mind yeah there are other
zombies in there but it's also a circle
around the shelves so he's not as long
as you don't slow down too much he's not
that much of a threat but he is if like
any of the zombies get in my wigs and
I'm saying like
there's no guarantee that he'll be in
there with you he might be like I don't
know you could learn out to the balcony
and come back in like he's I think he's
upstairs yeah upstairs waiting for me I
can hear him you have to go up there
anyway is he coming to me feel like I
deserve to know I honestly don't know
he's not like always doesn't always do
the same stuff could try being quiet
I think noise does factor in like how do
I learn him anywhere I think you're good
right now go upstairs the East our room
is good to bring him into because you
can loop around the shelves I'm sorry
okay I would I'm just gonna go to the
balcony and pray that he's not in there
yeah go to the balcony and then climb
down or don't climb down the ladder if
you did you make it to the where if you
make it to the balcony then you can go
back to the rest of the police station
you don't understand he's up there
is he looking for me yeah this sucks
I should have done everything first
before I met him this sucks
who was that where was that door what do
you mean I just heard someone open a
door you know the Bell okay so the
balcony is easy cuz it's pretty wide
open you if you get out there you're
fine I don't know where he is
I mean if it's as long as it's quiet I
would go get the stuff in the storage
room no I don't want to I'd say it's
worth it so you don't have to come back
unless he's in even if he's in there
like I would you could toss a flashbang
how are you like yeah he's scary but
like part of the game right now is to
like cat and mouse him around desks and
stuff what is that I think he's outside
like to your left so I I don't know this
is the worst oh god I hope he's not in
here yeah just go straight to that door
to the left
don't shoot
there's grenades on your left and then
go through that door
that's good that's a key item is there
anything else okay
oh there's a knife yeah [ __ ] coming
it's in the mannequin I hear him okay um
so yeah you're gonna go out to the
balcony and then down the ladder sorry I
was just like trying to like have a
system here so I want to go straight
straight and then through that door hard
right yeah he's fine that was so [ __ ]
loud and scary [ __ ] it I was perfect you
got everything you needed I would dunk
some
oh my god I'm getting an F I'm saving so
Attali
route just through doorways he's so
awful awful awful man should I have a
knife or a flashbang um so first of all
deposit the electronic box art the part
that you just got yeah
[ __ ] I'm trying to think if you need the
cog right now I don't think you do it's
just not a mistake I want to make no
definitely don't okay I would store the
cog you'll get that later and then the
knife yeah I think you're fine with the
flashbangs now you're gonna go out to
the balcony and back to the helicopter
he's gonna be outside isn't he yeah he's
not out there is he
he's he's the loudest person on earth
he's just out there this is a nightmare
Judy he's already gone downstairs
there's the only one way to find out I
would go upstairs comb sir just keep
going balcony
yeah yeah and then down the ladder [ __ ]
yeah I'm going I'm going
run [ __ ] yeah through there how fast he
walks he's like a Michael Myers oh where
am I going
okay so now you've been here so yes okay
I know where we are
oh okay so you have the code the safe
code you got is that exclamation point
right there you can go get that now if
you want isn't he yeah but I mean like
he you he's pretty far behind you plus
like the main hall is right next to that
anyway sorry I'm like so I'm actually so
scared I'm like having trouble like
paying attention wait open your map once
more and go down a floor okay I never
run okay yeah you're good so he can be
anywhere anytime
pretty sort of all right I got the code
for this safe behind there left six
right two to two and then left to 11 and
the next
mr. X mr. X great I combined this with
my gun yes with my good gun mm-hmm all
right
where do you want me to go now I think
we're looking for heart and diamond
doors I know zoom out so there's a
diamond door right there on the linen
room yeah also we can go get the
submachine gun now the of the USB all
right so I'm just gonna go take a left
into the main hall and then I could go
into the library and go into the lounge
and then into the linen room okay but I
would get the thumb drive from the say
box in the main hall so you can go get
the submachine gun where oh it's just in
the main hall computer no no no it the
the thumb drive Oh get it from a box
yeah this is too much man
yeah mr. X is a trifle terrifying
yeah he's passed it yeah now on oh right
it looks like a bad jack I keep thinking
it's like a badge all right join me
anything else no so you want to go
upstairs here and that way is that
Marvin yeah he's okay he doesn't look
great I would go to the library
that guy can't come in here right he
can't come in here right let's just save
room I they're here all right so take a
right at the library left into the
lounge right into the linen room library
lounge I'm so bad at this
is that the last time indoor yeah sweet
discarnate so what do you ask you this
if you discard a key you need can you
just like not be able to finish the game
no I won't let you discard a key you
need you can only discard key items to
have a what was that portable safe
puzzle thing might as well just do that
now literally for the rest of the game
I'm upset
well no not for a while but I don't know
you'll see I'm not
I don't wanna spoil the game for you I
want you to so I'll do that do that safe
you just picked up it's one of that
circle like puzzle things
wait wait
bottom right yeah no no no bottom right
yeah
yeah sorry yeah do we know them all now
top right [ __ ] I'm left got [ __ ] [ __ ]
alright okay it's this one okay this top
right top right now that one yeah it's
either bottom out bottom left right eeny
meeny miny moe
go right ha ha
another key for the weapons um I go get
the submachine gun now no just take a
right in this hallway and then go to the
stars the stars office yeah I [ __ ]
hear him walking around up there yeah
you're fine
I'm not fine I'm not fine he's here I
don't want to fight this man do I go
straight into the shower room out and
then take the stairs I'm trying to think
you might be able to Juke him in the
office yeah but he might not even know
you went into the stars office I'd say
stick to that plan go into the stars
office get the submachine gun get out
put the USB in the computer at least
put it put it in the computer to the
left
wait what the [ __ ]
there you go can i lock myself in the
gate no that'd be awesome though I know
he lifted a helicopter you could
probably bust through that gate sweet
there you go there's other stuff in here
I think - is there a way out - my best
see buds I can't read this
there's an air outside it's it's Chris
Redfield saying he's going to Europe
which is a lie but that's not so Mike
Chris I what am i doing I think you got
the thing check your map no I can hear
him is there anything else in this
armory I honestly don't care
okay you can Juke him cuz he's gonna
there's nowhere to Juke in here no no no
I don't mean joopa like when he goes to
punch you you can still like slip by him
quickly just like stick close to him
slip by him what do you mean close to
him like a lot of the bosses like they
have a reach so you want to like be
right up on their hip what you have you
can't really do anything else or you
could use ammo to stun him but I would
just try going by him wait why is he not
moving do I need this back no what else
is in here there might be other stuff
near the desks this is help
I actually I don't care I want to go
home okay yeah okay I would I can't
handle it my heart you want to know go
down a floor on your map not it I'm
sorry go up now you press l2 sorry now
go now go down a floor so that's a
clover room you can't do that so you got
the key for the safety deposit room
that's not gonna advance there's this
break room what's that oh that's
I could go to the safety deposit room
yeah might as well all right so is the
plan for me to take a right and go
downstairs yeah just making sure but I'm
like literally done in this room I don't
want to be here oh yeah you got the roll
of film too so when you're near the
safety deposit I'm so afraid like is he
okay either way no matter where he is
you have a good escape route here not no
matter what as I'm saying like if you
keep going you don't find him that's
good
this is a line rate I have to go to the
shower room yeah
[ __ ] I hear him okay abort go back the
other way to the main hall through the
library
I saw his stupid face oh I'm so much
faster than him that's like my only yeah
this guy then not you want to go through
the West office so just door at the
bottom of these stairs just go through
there to the safety deposit room so
right here at the West office the safety
deposit yeah and then to the dark room I
guess cuz you had that roll of tape film
he was yet um so get rid of that key on
there yeah oh my god so now you can get
the rest of those items like between the
liquors and the exes yeah I would
combine those really get hanger yeah I'm
gonna know don't save it for wait
another one back there wasn't it - 203
208 - three
[Music]
you could just do two or three before
you get those yeah more inventory
alright so I'm I'm almost dead oh I'm on
oh I can combine yes you want I'm on
caution I'd wait to heal oh you got
heart doors lay down Anna I feel like
this is a good place okay so actually
yeah let's just go to the dark room look
at the roll of film that we could save
in common wait there's a liquor though
should I kill him I would just avoid it
ah [ __ ] I'm trying to it's honestly you
do have flame rounds now I would just
kill it it's gonna be loud though and
mr. axe is gonna hear though you have
you haven't you haven't acid around
equipped just so you know I think flame
rounds can I get rid of it
oh my [ __ ] god did he just open the
truck just cat and mouse him around the
lockers where no just press r1 when
you're out of the menu that'll switch
the grenades this sucks this sucks so
much all right let's get to the dark
room in your set we're gonna take a left
you made your fine yeah let's look at
that roll of film before we call in an
episode
God you know liquor and mr. axe back
there I think he was too uh I think it's
in your inventory or say box the music
[ __ ] music will not allow it
God when I open that door I was like
just walk but the music was like you are
going to die it's going to be horrible
you probably get rid of the gunpowder's
as well we could worry about that next
episode let's just look at the roll of
film right now okay I felt so sure I was
gonna die sweet I'll write it down
dzm
sweet oh my god
stressful oh sweet part where I was
dodging him and the zombies I think will
like haunt me yeah well you have Monday
off in America to recover everybody
thanks as always for joining us at
GameSpot resident Knievel Oh also so for
next week's episode nothing is really
changing but because we are hitting such
a crazy busy season for game releases
and everything we're considering putting
knievel on GameSpot's gameplay channel
it's not confirmed yet
but so this episode will be on the
normal channel it's not confirmed yet so
I keep an eye on Twitter or whatever
we'll get the word out if that does
happen we're not positive yet it's still
in talks people want to watch like them
in a series yeah that's a good good
point so I'll mention that but right now
at this episode will be other normal
channel we might all be on the normal
channel but yeah thanks everybody for
joining and then as always join the
discord channel
Nathan Shepard in the comments usually
puts a link into the fan art and general
chat and play through stories channel
we're in there every once in a while as
well and thanks as always for joining if
you're in America have a good three-day
weekend if you're not have fun at work
Monday suckers no just kidding thank you
joining love you thanks for the oaf an
hour again Caitlyn bye what I was
thanking people